Donald Trump gave two speeches over the
weekend one was in Nevada to some
volunteers it was ridiculous I'm not
even going to cover that but I do want
to play a couple of clips for you from
Trump's speech in Council Bluffs Iowa
this one was particularly glitchy and as
you know Donald Trump's brain
malfunctions often during these events
but it actually seems to be getting even
worse in this clip you're going to say
Donald Trump you're going to hear Donald
Trump say that he will deny entry to the
United States to Communists which he
said before and I obviously can't
possibly do it makes no sense almost
certainly illegal and impractical but he
says I'm going to deny entry to
Communists and to markers markers I
think he means marxists and he says they
won't be allowed into our cunni I I
didn't misspeak what I what I mean I did
misspeak but what I mean is Trump says
they won't be allowed into our kunny and
if you're watching you will see Trump do
that glitch he does when his brain
malfunctions it's very weird and it's
getting worse I will also order our
government to deny entry to all
Communists and markets look we have
marxists
fascists Communists they're pouring into
our country we are going to deny them
access to our country now the one they
will not be allowed into our country
it's just not going to happen not if
Trump takes our Connie back that's for
damn sure so that was the most visually
ridiculous moment but there were also
some other
uh I don't want to say I felt bad but I
almost started thinking about maybe
considering the possibility of feeling
bad trumps asked a question here he did
this thing where he takes questions from
the audience and it's always funny
and said he's asked a question about
something he has no idea about it's
related to farmland and pipelines Trump
very obviously has no clue what this
woman is talking about and he just kind
of says it's terrible isn't it well I
have a plan I have a plan no connection
to the subject matter whatsoever
well you know we're working on that and
you know we had a plan to totally uh
it's such a ridiculous situation isn't
it
we had a plan to totally to do what it's
ridiculous
but we had a plan and we would have
instituted that plan and it was already
but uh we will get it but if we win
that's going to be taken care of that
will be one of the easy things we do yep
um hey how will you fix this thing oh
well it's terrible what's going on we
had a plan if we win we're going to do
it very quickly and it's just horrible
what's going on with that but we have a
plan you know that don't you this is
what you say when you quite literally
have no idea what the subject matter is
that you're being asked about Trump then
made the false claim that in blue States
you can murder children
okay listen to this they are the
radicals not the pro-lifers they tried
to make the pro-life is a red no no when
they're willing to go into eight nine
ten months
after birth after birth that was a past
actually saying it's okay after birth
they are the radical ones and this is an
issue if properly spoken about it's uh
because nobody wants to see that it's
not happening it's not true that states
blue states have legalized killing
children after a period of time many
people right from the beginning but
nobody nobody wants to see after four
months five months six months
death termination nobody wants to see it
okay so Trump of course just lying about
the situation with abortion rights and
in fact abortion rights have been
curtailed uh dramatically as a result of
the overturning of Roe v Wade we're
already seeing it in a number of
different states and it's disgusting and
horrifying lastly Trump with a little
bit of projection he's talking about Joe
Biden but you'd think that this is
actually about Trump a man we have a
president of the United States who's a
stone cold corrupt Faith oh and
who's willing to arrest his opponent
okay of course Biden no involvement that
we know of with the arrest or indictment
of Donald Trump and if we want to talk
about corruption and criminality trumps
the guy who now has what 70 charges
against him in total across two
indictments so the typical sort of
greatest hits from Donald Trump
struggling to speak very low energy
speeches in front of small crowds the
campaign is getting going and as bad as
this is the question of course is can
anybody beat this guy in the Republican
party is there any appetite at all for
something different than this polling
suggests the answer is no we have new
polling we'll look at it tomorrow
the weather is about to start warming up
and that often means sweating and
chafing and sticking sheath is the men's
underwear that once and for all puts an
end to all of that nonsense our sponsor
sheath underwear has designed unique
boxer briefs with an ergonomic
compartment built to keep everything
separate and dry and cool and
comfortable by allowing air to circulate
everywhere it needs to be no more
readjusting all day sheath offers a huge
variety of designs and patterns over
half a million pairs have already been
sold also check out their super
comfortable bamboo t-shirts sheath has
amazing customer service super fast
shipping along with over twenty thousand
five star reviews sheath is also
actively working with multiple
non-profits that deal with mental health
and homelessness which you support when
you get sheath underwear I've had a
great experience with sheath underwear I
know you will too head on over to
sheathunderwear.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for 20 off the link is down
below